es una muestra del apoyo total de eeuu a
ucrania durante su visita al país
europeo
anthony blinken secretario de estado de
eeuu se reunió con el presidente de
volodymyr selenski con quien discutió la
posibilidad de una invasión rusa
hemos constatado la clara preferencia
por encontrar una solución diplomática
al conflicto y desescalar la situación
y al mismo tiempo hemos dejado muy claro
a moscú que si decide reanudar la
agresión contra ucrania se enfrentará a
consecuencias muy graves en el face
y es que las tensiones siguen altas en
el este de europa con cerca de 100.000
soldados rusos en la frontera con
ucrania los ucranianos temen que se
repita una invasión como la del 2014 que
se saldó con la elección de la península
de crimea y un conflicto que sigue hasta
hoy en la región del donbass arena donde
ya estoy cansado de la guerra estoy
cansado de ver tanques por la ciudad
estoy cansado del toque que da porque
soy muy joven y quiero salir a pasear
por la noche pero no existe esa
posibilidad nieta cuevas mons en el lado
contrario rusia asegura haber una
amenaza en la militarización ucraniana y
la presencia de la otan en su zona de
influencia por lo que ha propuesto un
acuerdo de seguridad a la alianza
atlántica y todavía no ha obtenido
respuesta
no amenazamos a nadie con nada pero si
escuchamos las amenazas dirigidas a
nosotros nuestra reacción dependerá
obviamente pasos concretos que nuestros
socios como belarús con el que rusia
planea entrenamientos militares
conjuntos algo que occidente ve con
preocupación ahora el siguiente paso de
blinken será viajar a alemania donde
discutirá las represalias ante cualquier
posible ataque ruso